hmm your makeup is holding pretty well
you hold well Celine you will dwell on
you held on tonight so I don't know
what's holding whom but the crowd was
holding me
I've had many premieres in my life but
it's not because you've had many
premieres that the one that you're about
to do is like I've had premieres before
just another premiere every premiere is
like it's your first time mm-hmm you're
scared you don't want to disappoint your
crowd and they're still tweaking to do
till the last minute even if we would
have three more months we would still be
tweaking till the last minute fighting
yeah because you you have more and I
another idea then so tonight I when I it
was Showtime and it started I felt that
the crowd carried me supported me took
me in their arms and say hey it's your
premiere tonight you know they were
saying something we love you we got you
I saw that I got you I tried to count
the standing ovations I lost count
when people put their phones up and they
were cheering for you and they just felt
they were sending you their energy and
their support and I saw you get
emotional a couple times on stage what
was going through your mind wafers
wiping a tear well if I'm if I can say
next time instead of counting how many
standing ovations I'm gonna be I'm gonna
sound like pretentious right now you
count how many times they sit down it'll
be easier yes oh yes I am I am I gonna
sound really weird right now because I'm
like so many emotions it's because when
you go the adrenaline that goes on on
stage you bring it home at night and
that's why it's difficult
to to relax but Celine you crushed it I
mean do you feel you crushed it because
we all felt that you absolutely owned
this opening night washed it you crushed
it you slayed it you put it away you
were Queen Celine it was amazing
let me ask you uh you know you were
speaking in French for much of it so I
was just feeling the emotion but not
understanding the worst emotion that's
it that's the in music yes but what did
you want to say to the audience tonight
because I know at one point you did
mention Rene and what did you want them
to know about how you were feeling and
how he was with you today well first of
all I wanted them to know and I told
them a few times that how apprec-- how
much I appreciate the fact that they
came to my invitation which they
accepted and they were absolutely
amazing guests amazing but I just wanted
them to know that through the years
through my whole life in show business
since I'm so young they've been there
for me and there's been ups and downs
and right good moments and happy moments
and sad moments and taking risks and
taking chances and well in this this
tour feels like a big risk for you I
mean you you put it all out there and I
think what you said was this was the
first time you'd really done it on your
own without Rene but that's what I said
about Rene is that normally because they
said or I asked them if they were
nervous well I said not too much I don't
feel you but if I may speak for myself I
am a lady I said no let me rephrase that
I am a lot nervous because the person
that was doing all the preparation of
the tour who was you know Rene was doing
all of that and he knew pretty well what
he was doing what he was talking about
and now it's like
I have an amazing team boys I don't want
people to think that oh now Selena's
like doing this on her own
I'm flying away own but I don't do this
by my own I have a lot of people but I
think you did him proud tonight Selene
and I think everybody feels bad thank
you thank you so much
I wanted Rene to be proud I wanted him
to supported me and I think he did I
think he supported all of us and the
crowd I was like you were carried by
that crowd that's what I said it was
read the morning bank
can I ask I know you spoke to us about
how the boys are not with you but did
you FaceTime them or call them before
the show they did they FaceTime you
they had a message for me my two twin Oh
and also my he was in a hockey room and
he was just scary enough that of the
eyes and he talked to me sad my three
children wishing me a lot of courage and
he said I know it's gonna go well mom
and it's not easy but you've been there
before yeah we love you we miss you and
I can't wait to see you at them so it
sounds like that means a lot it means
everything do you have anything that you
keep with you a good luck charm or a
token or anything as you go on this
world tour or something to make sure you
you can touch that object and know
you're good to go yes I do I have one in
my hotel and it's my kids who gave it to
me and it's a postcard but it's made of
wood because I like to knock on wood
first position make sure you're good to
go yes exactly and he says we love you
mana and Eddie Nelson and I see no and
there's a little heart hole so it's
really sweet and I have the imprint the
mold actually of the hand of my husband
backstage so any one part of the show is
allowed to of course since he's gone to
because there is hands like that so you
can actually give him a hand and it's
made on a piece of wood so I can knock
on wood as well so every night I'm in my
dressing room backstage and my quick
change and I give them the hand
and I Nakano he's with me I want to ask
you about the meaning of the song I'm
alive the crowd went nuts when you
started to play that well tell us what
that song means to you I you know at
first I thought it was part of a very
cute movie and that it was a very sweet
and up tempo song and and it's positive
and it's got a good to put in point it's
got a good when you call only and I'm
alive when you say I'm alive I think the
fact that the people feel so good about
that song is yes it's a great song
there's a great rhythm but people go
through tough times as well and they
overcome sickness and things and when
they come out of this little things that
life imposed on them and they can
actually say I'm alive we have to live
one day at a time I have to ask you
about the fashion because we saw your
costumes backstage they're unbelievable
you're working this Bob how much are you
loving playing with the fashion Celine
yes I love the blonde Bob you do yes
it's amazing you look so good and I know
a Pepe and Sydney said that you're
really owning your looks we do want to
ask you I mean look you look so strong
and you are so strong this is the
courage tour but sometimes the tabloids
and sometimes the critics have come
after you what do you say to those
people who are being critical of your
body lately is there anything wrong
about my body
give me that bicep again Celine Dion is
like I mean I I do belly mm-hmm I do a
lot of stretching and I workout because
it helps my mind body and soul and the
flexibility and the breathing all that
and I've never had anything for
awakening in my body for myself in the
morning so for example here in Quebec
there's a fireplace I just have a switch
I put a blanket on before and I haven't
my trainer and she wakes up my by
by massaging so and it's so beautiful
but it you know when you work really uh
first of all if you could go back when I
was 12 years old my face was rounder
because you have more fat in your you're
younger and everything is more a little
bit uplifted this way and when you
mature you get even more elongated but
I've always been very thin and the fact
that people are for me I don't take this
as critics because or they are but a
minor in the business where there are
criticism because if you don't want to
be criticized you are in the wrong place
you are at the wrong place you know
first of all I I take the positive I
take what's good for me I leave this
behind what's not good for me I let my
management take care of that and if if
it's if it hurts anyone they will take
care of that and I need to focus on
what's right for me how I feel and last
but not least you can't please everybody
no you can can i play a 30-second game
with you Celine and then we're done it's
called the songs of Celine just tell me
what song you think of when I give you a
scenario okay what song do you think of
if your youngest boys if they reach that
age when they tell you they want to
start dating what's your reaction it's
already happening I have my 18 year old
well first of all every time that let's
talk about the twins they're gonna be
nine soon and for three four years
already every time they go to a bounce
house or bowling or place to play they
come back and they say we met some new
friends tonight and and then the other
one will say yeah and he has two
girlfriends a little flirty I like that
they they all call them I don't know if
you understand the meaning of their
friends and girlfriends and I have an 18
year old who's getting a girlfriend
she's very good mom approves that's
important I approve because she has a
sense of etiquette
like for example because all our hearts
will have been probably broken one way
or another and you don't want your
child's hearts to be broken and I hope
it never happens to them but life will
decide that but he's so much in love
right now and the fact that she took the
time to she had a scholarship and all
that in her parents help in the school
help so she could travel through Europe
and my son was with me so he saw her a
few times and I surprised him I asked
her to come she's a twin she came with
her twin sister oh wow and she came in
Montreal for a few days and it was like
he was so happy he said mom I don't know
how to thank you for and then she she
took the time to bring me a box of
chocolate oh and a gift for the twins oh
and she wrote me a letter
but handwriting and you it might sound
simple no she's very thoughtful she
didn't have to do that first of all and
she took the time to say thank you for
opening your house for to us what song
do you think of if a guy asks you on a
date no that is show tomorrow and I
gotta go to bed boy sorry what song do
you think of when you sellout show after
show on the courage world tour what
would I think what song it would
represent oh we're selling these shows
were adding dates the tour is killing it
which song will ya
courage and flying away oh but not by
myself
[Music]